精華生育 因為這個人必須經過政府的批准才能生孩子
而且必須按照政府分配的指標生 否則就要受到處罰
我在央視工作的十幾年 從來沒有碰過這個話題
作為寫入憲法的基本國策 精華生育不容之意
但是 在中國的一臺化政策 實施的第一天
就有一個人公開表示反對
第一 他會造成要老危機 第二會有勞動力和兵員的匱乏
第三 人口老化將改變整個經濟結構
此後 他向重要最高層寫信
申請以他的替代方案作為失聯
但是 他從來沒有得到推廣的結會
在不到四十年的時間裡
中國完成了從限制生育到鼓勵生育的尋回
兩種躺在他第一篇論文中曾寫過
未來 你們想要人們多生
至少會像今天 想讓他們少生一樣困難
您今天看到你當年的育言成為現實的時候
是什麼樣的感受
我本來 一個
用我們這麼大的一個國家做的一個理所
外路來證明我的證實
這是一個黑傷感的意思
這麼明顯的和人民發生衝突的
偉害人民的事業
這麼就彈劃著做了幾十年
那您認為應該怎麼做
公開補兵計劃手錄
成立自己做的一個外路
反射和發行
一個負責任的政府答應來這樣的
不講的話
我會繼續在重複過去的路上
我曾經每分鐘
就有三十八歲以外出生
每年出生的人數
達到兩千多萬的經驗數量
他們這樣吃
一天化政策在1979年開始
當時文革技術不久
中國仍然是計劃經濟體制
由政府向所有國民提供教育
醫療就業
進行 人口過多
嚴重的影響了經濟現象
最新的基勒
中央政府認為
必須大力提倡和推廣
一對夫婦只生一個孩子
目標是
到1985年
要將人口的自然增長率
降到千分之五
20000年實現人口的靈增長
當時的宣傳口號
是只生一個好
而三十歲的山西省黨
宵教是兩中堂
行論文
公開質疑這政策
你怎麼會想去挑戰一個
已經成為定局的政策
就是想說
把一台花對於農民來講
就給了不可能
至少讓農民省上兩個孩子
你說這個根本不可能
是來自於哪兒
在打釋的幾隻內
國家幾隻亞國
所有國家吃過了
對於農民來講
就不是這樣
四個老人
兩個勞動地閒停
誰口
還在講了一個孩子
這樣的解鑄
在農民那無法想象的
就是沒辦法生活的
當時有一句著名的口號
叫只生一個好
政府來揚了
2008年
當時我在揚事報到一個新聞
一個69歲的農民
持續過刀在北京戰場節
因為他沒有兒子
他也無力重填
用這樣的方式
想盡監獄揚勞
在當天採訪中
我們一個專家
說中央財政
對於農村的揚勞
多少投入
他說沒有
我說一分錢都沒有嗎
第二天這則新聞長輪投跳
我受到了批評
說你瞎追問什麼
這個新聞引起了最高層的關注
不過後來這個批評不來了之
因為半年之後
中央政府第一次出臺了
給農村的揚勞保障
每個人股數五塊錢
而這是計劃生意政策
已經實施了30年之後
1979年論文中
兩週朗已經預測了這樣的社會後果
1979年12月
全國人口領導會議
在程度召開
中國的人口學研究
在1950年代初
已經作為自產階級科學被取消
1964年之後
人口補查中斷了將近20年
學術研究的基礎分剝弱
它是當時少見的
公開質疑的聲音
兩中堂第一個發言
繼承委的負責人就坐在底下
對
他們什麼反應
那當然是反對的
其實怎麼能
能和黨的政策唱反調
您不覺得不合實疑嗎
後來用一種執著
認為我講的
就是這樣的到底
所以提供
我反對
我反而覺得
我需要進一步
卸向我的自由
這就這麼吵吵下來了
就在同一個會議上
兩中堂遇到了日後
他最大的學術對手
七級部
第二社集院
宋建團隊
他們引入了控制論模型
預測人口總是
經過前學生的推薦
上報政治局
文章的觀點是
如果繼續維持
1975年的生育率
到2000年
中國人口將超過14億
2050年將達到40億
大力提上只升一個孩子
他們的文章很快
在人民日報發表
反駁你的這些人
確實是未高權重
是不是
這你的力量更長大
您有沒有當時
有沒有在人民日報發表
文章的可能呢
沒有可能
你還是說對了
我給人民日報
寄過一家維當
而且也給人民日報寫了一段話
意思指導你們
不可能發表我這樣的維當
但是我希望你沒把他吹弱
讓提示指導
這個是在通行又不通的上課
我寄過一家
一家
看法了嗎
沒有
梁重堂連寫了五篇論文
來反駁送件團隊的觀點
他認為當對方說
最近20年人口老化
並不嚴重是
忽略了
他事關的正是25歲以下
這代人到晚年的時候
社會中有多少年輕人
會來支撐他們
1980年3月
當時的中共中央總書記胡耀邦
對一臺化政策有擔憂
他要求中半
召開左單會
聽取不同意見
特別提到了
梁重堂論文中所說到的
四二腰人口結構
和人口的老化問題
美就說
這個做黨會組織起來
是為了應對
這趟是討論您提出的觀點
但是您本來都被邀請了
沒有
但是對於地方的一個人
來講
你又沒有背景
你又收一地方
他完全很陰陋心
那有沒有其他的專家
或者學者
跟您觀點進四的人被邀請
沒有
所以會看對不掉的角度
最後從來沒有一些報告了
後面就改變了
不參加會議了
至於梁重堂提出的
四二腰家庭的問題
做黨會的結論是
考慮到年輕夫婦
都是讀生子女的概率偏小
和老人的自然死亡率
這種家庭不會太多
只剩一個
是所有與會者的共識
會後
中央以公開性的形式
向黨團員發出了
只剩一個孩子的唱一
按照中共當時的記錄
當時主管國家經濟的陳雲
推動了共開性出台
您怎麼能夠判斷說
胡耀邦當時是想做一個緩衝
到了八億年
劉仲淺會
到了十月份
胡耀邦就主持
純樓數據處
請教怎樣
向美國政府
教怎樣
講話
八言
一開始就很明確
就是
這樣在全國推行
做不下去
我在四十二從來
就沒搞過一句話
趙家在這次會議上
提出兩個方案
第一個
就是全面實行普遍二台
第二個
是在農村
只剩了一個女兒的家庭
允許他們剩餘二台
但是根據季生伟的
做他會結果
多弟的官員
反對這個方案
季生伟宣教
四前官員
陳建書
因為胡耀邦趙子楊
只是一線領導
不是核心領導
楊中棠的書中寫道
在向胡耀邦跟趙子楊
報告之前
陳范森你寫寫
給陳雲
曾寫也用
他在1979年內
段講話
並且得到了陳雲的支持
他說
先念同志對我說
實行最好一個
最多兩個
我說
再強硬一點
明確規定
只准一個
準備人家罵斷子決策
不這樣
將來不得了
中共當時寫道
在黨和郭家蓮
鬧人中
陳雲是唱道
只聲音一個的堅定制製者
他在全行立閉中
選擇了一代人
在聲音上的犧牲
為此
他自己寧可承受
段子決策的罵名
共產黨人稱之為
大人正
他只是
給陳雲寫寫
沒有給鄧小平寫寫嗎
因為對小朋友
鄧小平沒有
直接的
就一台在那
鄧小平
也是提上一座
我生一個孩子
那他有沒有反對過一台話呢
沒有開啟我
鄧小平
又改變更好話
這個政策
跟所有人對我
非常直接的關係
對吧
他限制了你
和你的後代
你的生活
和你的生命
身體
能為什麼
發言的人
反對的人這麼少
這一代人
他是那麼要求別人
他自己
也是這麼最重要的
他就是那麼認識的
他並沒有我意
但其實這樣
這是一個對
我們民族
對國家傷害
很大的影響
像這樣子
其實都沒有
即使就幹的
即使
什麼在去個國家的
糾纏的機制
你就畫你一個機場
你你又對政府的
資源的手段
1983年
新任國家繼承為主任
前信中
在全國推行大街紮運動
根據兩重黨的統計
當年
中國玉玲婦女
約1.4億人
其中進3分之一
也就是3千萬女性
要麼被強制解譽
要麼被強制流產
繼承我的文件
記錄了當年的做法
超家
豐門
雜鍋
八房子
毀壞裝家
前走生處
甚至突村危機
拉人有節
便向求盡俱重
周連親屬
相連
當年年底
前信中被免職
1984年春節
兩重黨決定
給胡耀邦的決心
這是以內
那個時代
叫做
計畫生意搞得
農民
迷佛調生
所以
我才能在這樣去做
有什麼細節
對您比較觸動嗎
就是有一個婦女
我們長至
有時候
我去開玩
有些婦女的
那種
愛戀的假設
沒有對話
那個假設
是以外出動
你能想說
有些人越黑
能想說
有些
迷茫
指導
這是以外領導的愛戀
又想為
自光能是這樣
等等
也就是說
我不寫在人家的動靈
我不說
在美人寫
不應該在
再給胡耀邦的信中
兩種堂寫到
計畫生意工作
長期建立在
與群眾對立的基礎上
違背客觀規律
他建議
實施晚婚晚
與家建格的
二臺生意政策
這封信
有沒有
胡耀邦會的趙子洋的暗示
或者受益
希望您從大學
我有我
隔壁和胡耀邦趙子洋
沒有任何關係
所以您就這麼單槍疲嗎
玩家是我自己爭取家的
血腥爭取家的
正好遇到內部人
然後就我家寫成什麼
所以我到後來
我講
醫生寫的
誰還是不可福祉的
1984年3月29日
胡耀邦讓信訪局
把梁諾堂的來信
轉給了
基生為的主任王偉
基生為內部討論
否定了梁諾堂的意見
但當時在場
有越規劃出的感覆
叫張小童
他另行組織了測算
認為梁諾堂的方案
有道理
就像諾堂會報
很快
胡耀邦跟趙紫陽
都做了批示
要求有關部門
認真測算
並且帶中央起草文件
向下推行
講如此是承真
中國人會在1985年
得到普遍
生兩個孩子的可能
梁諾堂是在半年之後
在一個老幹不冒險
向他提供的婦嬰見中
他才看到了這份中央批示
但是
一直到那時
也沒有任何測算
更談不到文件
於是在1985年的1月份
他決定
給中央書記書書記
胡錫麗寫信
你什麼身份寫信
給他要求要
人事
他是也是專案領導嗎
那您是誰呢
我就是一個普通的黨員
如果連總書
都推動不了的事情
您怎麼覺得您能呢
在這樣的情況下
我應該什麼開
沒有別的路的河東
已經給回想忘寫過寫了
再也推動了
那麼
也藉口做了
吃點
做了食業
也算是
做著往前開
還有什麼路的
在張小銅的幫助下
1985年的7月份
梁中堂的要求
得到了批付
山西省推薦了一層線
作為實點地區
選那兒最重要的因素是什麼
對您來世嗎
就是選用手機的句話
什麼話
還沒講完
他就說
老大
你就把世界放在我家
就是食業不成功
對話又什麼害群
就在句話
我知道這次很明白
當時一層的機成資料顯示
這個地方有5000個
獨勝子女的家庭
所以很多人都很擔心
政策一旦放開之後
會出現大量的強生
梁中堂也很緊張
他跟當地一塊
制定了很詳細的預案
不過
沒有用生
5000個
獨勝子女家庭
都是假的
假的
又給了沒有死了
這是統計包包要上的手機
那這爆表怎麼寫傷害的呢
這就是計畫生意志度了
自己有就
獨勝子女
那麼我就給你包走生子女
這個獨勝子女是拿的
是
今年剛出生的
從
從獄的孩子
一
沒有來得及審第二的孩子
這就是獨勝子女嘛
然後到了第二年
第三年又沒有
來去追究
這就
差別包的
獨勝子女生
生沒想好二台
這是他累積的
獨勝子女
終於在那的發酷
那就接累了
獨勝子女姐來聊天
聲音高富沒有出現
新政策
一戶尋常的評論落地了
一年之後
林芬地委
想在全區推廣一程的做法
他們立下軍令撞
承諾完成指標
梁中堂的連署這份文件
而且代地委的官員
去北京
找寂審委主任
王偉會報
我聽到這麼幾個月
那已經帶了
無流片
就
那王偉
帶不出來
北京都不知道
一般人在這種情況下
會寫信節
是
你那個信
我有權力
幫我的一些
像
黨和國家反映
你也必須
請寫我的一件
從王偉的回憶先來看
這兩個人
在紙上
發生了巨烈的政策
王偉批評
梁中堂對中央不敬
承認
他對梁中堂有看法
其中一個原因
是梁中堂
把自己批評
計畫生意政策的書
送給了一位美國學者
在他看來
他在把了立場有問題
在一部書
不就是一顆定時炸彈
不知道什麼時候
在美國就報了
這個時候
你誰敢使用兩個拔手
這給你造成的後果是什麼
就是我到工作
想要走那裡
想要走
吃午餐
這過程中
您家裡人有沒有
勸過你
說別幹了
沒有
對我重回的遊戲
很愛
我要做什麼
從來沒有大我
相信
相信傳遇的
自己有
1986年
一層市底
面臨需要往的風險
此時
中國的人口出生率回升
送建所在的國家科委團隊
向中央承送報告
主張堅持一臺皇
其中再給趙紫陽的父親當中寫
請取消成命
收回市底
胡耀邦根趙紫陽都沒有表態
但在半個月之後
新華社和人民日報
都專載了科威的報導
實行計畫生育
不可稍有攜帶
當時的中央書記書書記
胡錦麗批示
再成報告觀點
堅決停止各種開口子的視點
感覺
二到五起的這個趨勢
那麼我們又回到一臺皇室
又沒有條件來研究
和討厭一生一生三味多
那麼就和他做個告別吧
我看的時候我並沒有覺得您是在告別
我是覺得您是一種很簡直像戰鬥
是啊
跟我在一場在鬥
就告別了
在中國人口戰略人道會上
兩種當宣讀了他的兩篇論文
批博柯文化告
認為出生率提高
是60年代高峰期出生大量人口
到了生育年齡的結果
另外的原因
就是因為一臺化政策不合實際
無法操作
造成放任自留之後的增長
他的論文題目
只指宋建團隊
此時宋建設國務委員
國家柯偉主任
您在大會讓發言的時候
宋建團隊的人在做嗎
法輩就快了一個碩士人
又生了
我從他那裡
特質宋建的政院一種官司
就是因為中國在這個華家的官司
都在農民
那麼相互的瞧瞧
國際有什麼意義
認為這個國家和民主
發展過程
我一定要是
其中一品種
宋建有這樣的反過
所以我用這個學生
代表有東西批博他
你說什麼
農民在批評的
也有權利活
也有他自己的幸福
也有他自己的環弱
就在廊農堂
準備告別一程式典的時候
1986年
12月2日
在全國際化身議會議上
趙紫陽第一次
公開提到一程式典
他說
山西我們還寄予希望
如果最後證明是好的
順呼民心
何呼民心
又能控制人口
當然好了
何樂而不為
但兩年之後
全國兩會之前
光明日寶刊登了文章
有關專家認為
我國人口現狀不容樂觀
掌關意志的感染
是出生率回生的重要原因
這個掌關意志當時是誰
我記得他們
鼓勵的毛頭是
都是羊
此事胡耀邦已經在學潮中去指
趙紫陽是當時的
中共中央總書記
在三月份
他直接回應了質疑
說計畫生意是基本國策
但從來沒有人說過
一對夫婦只剩一個孩子
是基本國策
提上只剩一個
什麼時候也沒有講過
這是法律
是命令
他說強迫命令引起的
飲產、逃家、逆鷹
為備了人道主義
在這次會議上
剛剛上任的
繼承為主任彭佩雲
問趙紫陽
說一程線的效果很好
要不要推行
趙紫陽再次說
他寄希望
但現在廣泛推開沒有把握
還需要世界
只不過
歷史沒有在給他世界
1989年
趙紫陽
你看這個重要
這樣買是買完一些了
實際上現在一些問題
還在逐步的接近
當年十月份
中央工作會議上
趙紫陽的人口政策
被當成資產經濟优化
受到疲憊
時任國家副主席王珍淑
這幾年農村人口失控
與包產刀鋪有關
與趙紫陽同志主張開口
紀有關
國務委員送建書
按現在的增長速度
五國到兩千年
將超過十五億人
陳雲和王珍說過多次
趙紫陽同志
在這個問題上
就是停不進去
前繼承為主任前信中
引述了國務院總理李彭的批評
說趙紫陽同志
對於重大政策
變換頻繁
急不慎重
在人口問題上
就採取了這樣的方法
幾個月之後
當林鐵印在山西市場的時候
說議程是照這樣的事例
你聽到這句話
這是什麼感受
九年遠遠
前過趙紫
在北京趙紫
中國人口頂綠頭的會
我在大會發言
有人講
一生實驗是
趙紫陽的思點
一生實驗
是1979年
我在第二次
全國這個理會
考慮非常提出的
外匯外匯
延長生育
普遍生育
二孩的一個
劇情實驗場
這是學者的
學術管理表
與實驗的結合
我們不能以為
89年的政治分剝
就把趙紫陽
參與的所有的
重大世界
都否定了
您心裡面
有沒有考慮過
這些屬於正面
對抗了有點
那我必須
實際上我的正義
我記得
解決就是
用政治
以生來
解釋我們學術的總理
是
學術染絡
在於不表現
您講這樣的話
您不覺得
有可能會付出代價嗎
沒想那麼多
反正我講了話以後
中間的
內部的
去房價
去開放
是嗎
這個
還想給您
忽如自豪的
講這份
我幾十年走過來了
有許多的
學術讓的
對比樣
幾乎所有的
學術對比樣
他們那些
都可以
可以進化進入我
因為我從不和他們
便利學術
以外的關係
我視頻的東西
都有實實在在的
不同
同意時期
幾乎用同樣的方式
蓬佩雲在中央
保住了
照樣的第二方案
就是允許農村
有女兒的家庭
是個兒臺
這覆蓋到農村
將近五億人
為了稅付中央
她在文件中
列出了
大量農民
和基層寄生幹部的暴力衝突
甚至樣子
又小孩子的殘列細節
楊農堂說
蓬佩雲此事無路可推
只能說出真實
不過
最後
她上任前
就提出過要去的議程
再也沒有提過
而梁中堂
也沒有在主動
給基層寄生為寫過
任何報告
只到她必顯的
你不是自討沒經嗎
對一位人的時候
您心裡面認為
這個議程事點
已經沒有前途了
早都知道被前途了
只是一個
我要去
要先是
不能讓她
再回到一臺話區
先是這個承諾
給誰的承諾
我可以一承的承諾
現在說一句講
就是這樣
你就是
不成功了
對我有什麼害羞
講這話的時候
我要給她講
就是不成功了
你們也是
有一個農媒
可以三兩拜的
正式
我絕對不會讓你們
再回過來
那時候
我就承諾
所以我幾十年
來就吸收這個承諾
這個時期
被山西社神偉
安排到了一城線
擔任分管
計劃生育的現位夫書記
如果她有第三個孩子
怎麼辦
你會要求她
不可以嗎
沒有求
那不能這樣
是怎麼處理
多太喊就有的
就能和她
我也不表態
我也不提名
那等於在現實中
設計的方案
晚婚晚餘
家健隔兩胎
都被突破了
都後來知道
給別做不到
為什麼
做不到
比較老北京的生活
是由她的
聚集的
巧姦所決定的
她能不能
找著對象
找下媳婦
什麼時候
能接回
她都要用
警戚巧姦
用虛擬
這都是
可管巧姦在那邊
這不是很簡單的事情
所以
懂得這個道理
有
就不去
要求你
指上的共同
最後
梁忠濤
不再看繼勝辦的報表
她只看人口不察數據
1985年到1995年之間
一城線的
平均總和生育率
是2.158
低於4.4點之前
也低於
山西省
和全國的平均數據
她認為
這個數字說明
一代化政策沒有實質疑
影響生育率的是其他因素
就是年代初
奴名公進城
生活方式巨變
中國的總和生育率持續下降
接近
甚至可能已經低於
世代更低水平
梁忠濤發出了警告
要求放鬆管制
全面實施而害制度
但是
1991年
計劃生育實行
一票否決制
生育指標被納入了幹部靠核
為了扭轉排名
山東省
發生了百日無海事件
從當年5月到8月
這個線下去
內所有的女性
不論懷地姬猜
懷到第幾個月
一律流產
來確保全線
沒有一個孩子出手
類似的事件
當時很少
就用公開討論
寄生系統免受批評
並且在中央媒體
設有固定要宣傳覽目
在我們的寄生站線上
有許許多多平凡的幹部
他們為了自己所熱愛的事業
吃苦受累了許多年
即便是這樣
他們依然甘願
奉獻自己的青春和生命
梁中濤無法得到官方報道的機會
他就自己邀請媒體和學者
到一程調查
當時是不是有人提醒過您說
你只做但不能說
我說我再又不是
頭來的蘿蔔不能敲
我要再填裹推行的
我為什麼敲這樣
我又幾回事
我又帶著媒體的寄生
就去
你想
你為什麼非用這個方式呢
一個人只有強大
他才又存在在這裏
一個事務也是他只有強大
這種強大
你如果一直在他手上
就被鞋子弱
那麼
他會請意的
就把他恰死
所以有記者去採訪國家寄生委的時候
提過一個問題
說既然如此
為什麼不在全國推行議程的經驗呢
你後來給記者回答的時候
議程有一個專家在那裏
你知道
意思是前國是兩三千個鞋
不可能給每個鞋
推出的專家
所以請專家介紹一下經驗
至少從八九年開始
我每次去了以後
我就是打破壞
一定把一些這個
計劃成立的北知識
什麼的
你走的事越多
加拿鐞貴賢越多
他贏了你
知道不知道
他快
那百姓超生了
所過的錢要給錢
要四幾匪 pay的
所以從那百姓
來裏面
總是賣錢
五塊錢
那麼計劃成立不門錢
都花一塊錢
所以你走的事情越多
對老百姓的上海越多
這麼聽起來
您是從根本上
就懷疑您這個事點
本身的意義了
別的計劃是一代化
我這個計劃日月就容於
那些兩個
真是不同而已
但是
它的制度和性質
自己回事
所以從200年以後
我就不再提
退行
活著事情一整的
二孩政策了
我改變了一種違反
這計劃生育了
離開一程之前
梁諾堂把他的研究資料
會走
自應了兩本書
他寄了一份
到中共中央辦公廳
請他們轉交給
軟靜重的趙姐
那是我自己告別他
這家事
可以交怎樣也得交代
我要把我不是已經走交了
這個交代是指什麼呢
不是趙子央
用過兩次
講話
有意成這個系列
是基督希望以
這個系列
那麼這個系列
怎麼回事
最後是什麼
覺得
能夠關切這個問題的
這個
從過去來上
就有這個問題
其他人來關切都不關切
再更新
更沒有意義
最後
梁諾堂去往
上海社會各水院
開始系統研究
計劃生育的歷史
他的研究認為
計劃生育這個概念
並不是像之前
從沒得中了解到的那樣
來自於知識分子馬英出
這個概念的發明權
來自於毛澤東
是他定義了計劃生育
唯有十多生
有十少生
是調固的需要而定的邏輯
新中國成立之後
的人口曲線
出現及不尋常的波動
也正式
這個邏輯的推演
1949到1953之間
在毛澤東
批判馬爾薩斯
人口論的背景之下
國家衛生部
禁止了避孕和流產
這加劇了
中國的第一次生育高峰
人口突破留意
1957年
毛澤東提出了結育
但是大育進期間
迅速轉向
提出人多力量大
此後
中國人口在大跡荒中
急劇下降
1962年之後的
補償性生育
在沒有結育服務的情況下
帶來了中國人口的
第二次生育高峰
此後
毛澤東再次改變判斷
提出
人口非控制不可
計劃生育由此
向農村全面展開
到1978年
中國女性的生育力
已經接近了更廢水平
但這個制度並沒有提出
反而在毛澤東去世之後
推向更加嚴厲的
一臺華政策
您幹嘛要把自己的時間
放在研究這段歷史上去
計劃生因是中國
工廠黨的大政策
它是從中央上層
自上而下的
推薦的一種東西
現在國家補工事務
是由於老百姓的生活
而產生的一個工事務
委託政府來做的
這是想法的路徑
政府這個角色到底應該幹嘛
政府公權和
公民的私權
這是兩個命運
有交叉的
但是生育為勤
沒交叉
這是虛擾和國際國際公約
共同確定了的
是走足規定被人類
本性決定了的
從來生育為勤
共同公民不敢遇的
不察遇的
您曾經說過一句話
您說
胡耀邦跟趙僭館
想在內部做出一些改變
但他們從根本上還是認可
計劃生育
這麼一個觀念的
對
對他們把自己關在了
自己親手塑造的制度的籠子裡
對
現實就有
從此要接受的
計劃緊急事社會主義
幾位制度
我早期都非常
懂得建議
我們從過
有對閃避的社會制度
美國
這些國家
都是復修的社會制度
你這是這樣的內容
您那時候
怎麼向自己解釋社會的貧窮呢
那時候我不認為
自己貧窮
那為什麼會把人口當中負擔呢
改變都不會想說
其實你趕在
其中來的問題
為什麼要把美國當中負擔
美國就是負擔
這不是一個備論嗎
如果
沒有備累
因為沒有那麼多的
問題
沒有那麼多的思想
我們
做計劃生育
其實
現在來做了一個就像
唐基河的
和大風車做動身的樣子
做了這麼一件事
您的意思是
敵人並不存在
是啊
就是折騰了老北京
製造了社會模擔
做的一段歪落
到2001年
中國的總和生育率
僅為1.22
已經出於世界最低水平
國家人口發展研究報告
確認為
從90年代中後期
這個數字一直在1.8左右
並且穩定之間
而且未來30年
應該一直保持在1.8
兩中堂成1.8
為一個政治數據
十幾年比值得這麼一條線
這符合常識嗎
這符合常識是統一的節目
這計劃成一部門
可以拿待的
決策者真的相信嗎
這樣的數字
這是一個一眼
從來沒有一個
可以帶它
不認真不是有後果的
這個就是後來計劃成一部門
反對放開二臺的理由
如果放開普遍二臺
那麼就會有個生育高峰
4995萬了
事實上是多少來著
從姐姐兩下的
一次下降到現在7.8
成日就已經頂到
比韓國還領點去一下了
2012年
中國的生育率
低於時代更低水平
已經持續了將近20年
在這前後
有一圈70後女性
突步走到一城
申請接入顧口
在那十二臺
很多人寫行鄉兩中堂求助
你是什麼感受
大師已經哭了那些感受
就像那一年內心
喜歡別選一樣
這種制度
環繞本樣
幾多那樣的
規則上
你看
又一跡離美糊
打算發生於好制度
這個
這改結束不值得
就在這一年
發生了安康孕婦的
強制營產世界
引起全國轟動
中國人口學界數十位學者
聯名上書
建議改變政策
但是兩中堂
不同意這個方式
我參加他的會了
大師認為我拒絕像一個
為什麼
這時候已經很清楚了
計劃生意已經不是
一台二台的問題
而是應該不應該
結束計劃生意的問題
別人會覺得說
您會不會太理想主義
了在
當前的國情相
不是比想
是北南國家公共事務
就應該是這樣
我的要求
是最值得要求
最值得要求
就在這次會議上
他說
社會必須改革和進步到
讓所有的人
都可以公開發出自己的聲音
明確講出自己的觀點
提出自己的要求
歷史
已經超越了
民軍新冠的時代
社會呼喚民主和法治
這篇文章的題目
叫做
計劃生意法
是中國法學的持物
2014年12月
在上海的一次會議上
他當著十任
全國人大
富裕員長
彭佩雲的面
說出了這句話
我可以不科技
或者狂往
校長的
這樣
在這個大城裡
最有值得
普通計劃生意
是我娘中堂
為什麼假成我嗎
我從青年時代
就投入到這個事業
做了這麼幾十年
我把我一生的生命
我給了她
然後發現
她應該是一個
普通的和老百姓
對你的
所以
應該
普通她
這有資格
普通她的
就是我
其實
是有一次
自己
狂可以
是
你是想讓她
但我指導
這次會議
她會來的時候
我把
這個
在
博客上面
發表的計劃
有關
法治的
會議在一起
起了一個面子
就是以不合法
我是
惡劣的惡
以不合法
為計劃生意法
這層
有一個小
小色子
我檔面
受到空飛雲
她是當年
在她
這台
法律出台的嗎
是吧
就是她一手出台的
那你把
那本書放了她面前
起不就是
一個
像戰術嗎
我說彭惠銘
人家想得好
還最不錯
我用
我這樣做
包括我當
家家委員的時候
笑聲的會議上
常常
不通意她
講的話
公開
講得我的
幹部
她不在於
那您為什麼
還是參與呢
這總是一個
法對
現狀的
一共力量
而且
是一個長大的力量
2015年
北京大學
舉辦研討會
為即將修改的
計畫生預發
提供建議
兩眾堂被邀請了
她也去了
但是在
閉門討論階段
她把那本
一本惡法
論計畫生預發
派發給
每一位學者之後
就離開了
2015年
兩兩眾堂
呼籲了30年的
全美二孩政策
終於在全國時事的時候
英國太務實抱的
記者採訪她
請她
評價一下
幾個歷史公寫
她說
沒有公寫
對方說
你不要謙虛
她說我沒有謙虛
這是走一個學者來講
我寫的
遜到東西
總有一顆的發表
就即使
現在的全正式
發展變化了
但是
在
總要改變以前
沒有
幾個
或者一個
她
體一個小走
到一身寫走
總結
看看
一身寫的
有什麼經驗
沒有
所以
我走一個學者
我自己
就不能
認為
我個人有什麼公結
或者一身寫的
十點
有什麼工作
但你覺得她的存在
本身
就是她的價值
但實際
歷史中她存在了
所以她的距離還是
就
她的存在了
算是一個參照誤
從1985年
十點開始
每一年
對我不少
一成老百姓
給梁濃堂的季小明
那是那裡的特產
她的大股長
當中當告訴
她吃了
40年的一成小明
這是普通人
給她的認可
在寫給梁濃堂
教授的第一封信中
我說
作為一個零分人
我向零至今
到2025年
中國60歲
積以上人口
達到3.23億
佔比越23%
人口老零話
在農村地區
有違言重
零到14歲人口
這些
是梁濃堂在1979年
能文章中
做過的愚怕
2016年
中國允許所有夫妻
生意而抬
五年之後
又改為
允許生意三抬
我雖然已經吃了多了
但還沒有到
唐平的年輕
我真是生三抬
我們不法是這一點
現在在做想法的路
鼓勵
那麽
很有可能
在鼓勵的過程當中
繼續走路
怎麽講
因為
我們並沒有法師
所以現在
還在這裡干預了
鼓勵也是干預嗎
現在開序的小產
去到保持調節
和當年
1979年
其上一個夫妻生意而孩子
一模一樣
那個菲薇和感覺
都希望這樣
那時候
給菲薇不會想說
後來發生了
這麽我覺得
最重要的事件
哪會發生
那也行
因為決策也有一種
急迫的心理
覺得說
現在這個人弄結了
這就他回到
未來的北脂
不是政府
你應該查受
政府查受的
你一定沒消過
而且這個消過
一定會
實在氣犯
今天看到人口數字
你沒有教律嗎
沒有
我沒有用
很大的行李來管住
這一個結果
我管住的是
雷維的社會摩擦
你改賽了
社會就沒這個摩擦了
老百姓就沒這個在那了
究竟中國應該是
十億人口
二十億人口
三十億人口
或者十五億
十三億
這都不是
全世界
不同數據的國家都有
並不是你是哪一個
數據就好
哪一個數據不好
而是你
這個民主國家
實行了
這樣的社會制度才好
是這樣的危機
開啟
聲譽率不需原因
而是結果
中國應該考慮
都不是直接的人口政策
而是持續改革
讓市場經濟
釋放人
尤其是人主體人口的
農民的活力
兩眾黨的協作
多數情況下沒有讀者
我在東西
在這東西
在國內
其實
自己自己的城市
找的散發
反正沒有內合影響
因為其實
那些家伙
從不做學位
從不進一步讀書的
你媽的
她的東西她都不多
你人的感覺
好像幾十年
都是一種單打獨鬥
所以我不是
有些人
我就是我
如果你
幾十年
你的觀察
要好
你的思考也好
都沒有
什麼公開說的機會
對
我的東西
打完
比較小
在中國
知道
可能
我還經歷了
你就說
你多了
但是
多從又脫了
總是
那個小出版
是在出版
總還是
又不容易
能開
對
那幾天
我跟你回新一集
我就想
就有才經
一個人開車了
那你自己幾十年
裡面
會不會有
有孤立的感覺
你為什麼
沒有
可是嗎
我還能夠
自由的
發表我的
開發和認識
我沒有
給我過去
講的
一些總結
生活中
裡面
那樣講的
你這麼現在
有這樣講
我能夠
始終
如意的
以歸的
來講生活的總結
就
這個
就只有這個
小的
就勾了
在那樣的時候
留下它
有什麼
有什麼用啊
雖然沒有意義
但是我
抗爭我
我
身數
我將求
這是
做
做最基本的總結吧
就是
人種子
和一個螞蟻不一樣
請您的長官
跟您的面子
一時
生活後
已經記錄講了
記錄
我們
這個
每次我
衝行
吃水果
發塑果
發抗果
又過另外一種
上衣